so I think what's really fascinating is
that there have been a number of recent
studies looking at brain structural
differences between liberals and
conservatives and what's been found in
several studies is that liberals tend to
have a larger anterior cingulate gyrus
that is an area that is responsible for
taking in new information and that
impact of the new information on
decision-making or choices conservatives
tended on the whole to have a larger
right amygdala amygdala being a deeper
brain structure that processes more
informational information specifically
fear-based information so the it's
really responsible for the flight or
fright response and this isn't everybody
it's not black and white and of course
then you know what about all of the
people in the middle but basically the
studies showed that if you just based it
on brain structural size difference you
could predict who would be a
conservative and who would be a liberal
with a frequency of seventy one point
six percent seventy one point six
percent is a pretty high ability to
predict who is a conservative and who is
a liberal just from brain structure when
you look at what your parents were in
terms of predicting what you might be in
terms of conservative versus liberal
that enabled you to predict in studies
at a rate of 69 point five percent so
very close not quite as good and why is
that interesting it's because the brain
is plastic so the question as to whether
you have a brain structure to start with
that informs whether you will be a
liberal or conservative or whether the
formation of certain thoughts from your
parents for example shapes your brain
structure because the brain is plastic
and ever-changing particularly in youth
so does thinking certain thoughts or
predominantly let's say utilizing your
right amygdala versus your anterior
cingulate gyrus in four
the growth of those areas and therefore
help you predict later who is liberal
and who is conservative so in terms of
interpreting the meaning of different
size structures for a liberal versus a
conservative I think you have to look at
what that area is predominantly
responsible for so for instance for
conservatives if your right amygdala is
enlarged and that's the fear processing
area you would expect maybe choices or
decisions or character and personality
to be more informed by a response to a
fearful situation so for example
conservatives in fact in personality
studies do tend to rate higher in areas
of stability loyalty not liking change
being more religiously involved in terms
of decision making having that that rate
higher for them in making certain
choices and if you look at liberals from
a personality character standpoint
you're going to find stronger ratings in
terms of like and change wanting to
actually base decision-making on new
information on science information and
so those differences are not surprising
in light of these brain structural
differences being a liberal or being a
conservative really is not black and
white it's really a bell-shaped curve
where you know someone who considers
themselves conservative may be far less
conservative so to speak then someone
else who still calls themselves a
conservative and that bell-shaped curve
continues all the way through we're in
the middle there may be a large group
that calls themselves independents what
we don't know is whether that has to do
with differences in brain structure and
so would we see an independence no one's
done that study to say oh independents
don't show any differences in brain
structure or any differences in say
risk-taking reaction so we don't we
don't know for sure what that means but
I think it's fair to say that even when
we looked at differences in brain
structure with a reliability of seventy
one point six percent that still leaves
you know a very large number that don't
fit into that category so you know where
do they fall out are they more likely to
be independence in their mind we don't
know the answer to that but certainly
you know these are not hard and fast
rules this is not diagnostic science and
and and people who are independent
obviously have certain characteristics
I'll say of both sides are somewhere
just like they sound in the middle I
think by understanding what's going on
structurally in the brain and
functionally in the brain we can better
understand what informs people's very
strong opinions that ultimately inform
our political system right because it's
one-person one-vote and in trying to
change people's minds I think everybody
has to look at what's behind the ability
to change a mind you know is it really
changeable when when we look at voting
and and changing minds and say political
advertising you have to recognize that
all of that new information always comes
in through the prism of your brain which
means that what I say to you versus you
may be heard differently even though
I've said the same thing so it comes in
through the prism of does what you said
make me nervous and afraid and therefore
I'm going to resort to my old standby I
don't want to change my decision or am I
going to hear the same information and
say oh that's novel I have a receptivity
to novel information therefore that's
interesting to me and I'm going to think
about whether I might change my mind
based on that new information I think
that's what the science is basically
saying to us that there are going to be
some people who are going to hear the
information
and retreat to their original thinking
and other people who are going to hear
new information and say that really does
change my mind if we're trying to have a
society that will work in its own best
interests let's say then we do want to
be able to communicate with one another
and so if you are a liberal and say you
want to talk to a conservative about gay
marriage you want to have in your mind
how it might still speak to loyalty
stability and religious belief in some
way that you want to have those ideas
inform your communication as opposed to
simply saying but you know this
percentage of the population is
homosexual and therefore you know we
should consider whether everybody should
have those same rights and you know
science shows it's not a choice it's
it's simply a fact you're gay or not gay
and therefore shouldn't those people
have the same rights that's not the best
way to appeal perhaps to a conservative
on this issue you want to appeal to them
in terms of how for example marital
rules or history might be maintained and
not really altered for those who are in
let's say a quote traditional marriage
how it won't interrupt the fabric for
example of their lives of the rules that
they adhere to those kinds of things
would be more appealing to them whether
or not that might be the most appealing
argument to you as a liberal the truth
is a conservative is more likely to be
able to appeal to a liberal using novel
new information that is science-based
and showing certain facts and allowing
for it not necessarily to be purely
religiously based that not be the rule
system so to speak by being empathically
understanding and by that I don't mean
sympathetically understanding I mean
truly being able to stand in the other
person's shoes and have some insight
into where their brain
is directing them and appealing to that
argument so if you are conservative you
will want to appeal with new information
because liberals are more novelty
seeking potentially and and often
science-based is a good way to present
new information part of what's difficult
in terms of what I am seeing now is that
actually people are tending to double
down on their own style and what appeals
to their own group of thinkers and that
is increasingly preventing the kind of
communication that would be important to
our futures so that we can't so to speak
cross the aisle because it would require
trying on for size the thought pattern
of the other group it would be saying
you know oh you know I fee and that's
hard to do let me say that is difficult
to do so if your amygdala is screaming
at you you know run for the hills or you
know double down and fight it's hard to
say well let me take a step back and not
have a fear-based reaction but instead
present the science or present the new
information a good example would be that
of gun ownership if I speak about gun
ownership to a liberal group they
automatically have thoughts probably
about particularly if they're in an
urban area crime and danger because
statistically that is what they have
been privy to the information has been
given to them about how many homicides
are committed who is you know dying by
gun violence etc if I speak about gun
ownership to a conservative group they
are more likely in their loyal stable
way to think about a sportsmanship
hunting with family particularly again
if they're in a rural area because that
is what they grew up with that is what
has been stable for
that is the memory that they have about
guns and so you can see how that's
coming from two completely different
directions perhaps the same word gun and
that it is hard to stand in the shoes
for example of the of the other group so
that you can you can come to make
decisions about it so for example the
CDC has been prevented from doing any
research so that we could have new
science about gun violence as a public
health issue by actually the
Conservative Political group has said
you know you you can't do research on
this area we won't call it a public
health issue and therefore you're
prevented from getting dollars and
prevented from having research into gun
violence per se and that comes probably
from a fear position that if there is
any new information that sways opinion
we will lose our loyal standing to
something that we firmly believe in and
and harks back to very pleasurable
comforting memories from earlier life so
it's very complicated in a certain kind
of way you know the liberal group is
wanting there to be this research not
necessarily to take guns away but to say
we'd like to see the science to validate
whether or not certain things about guns
or good for us or not good for us
the most recent study looking at what is
going on in the brain in terms of
politics predicted with the greatest
value being able to identify a
conservative versus a liberal 82.6%
and this was a look at brain activity
which is different you put someone in a
functional MRI which is different than
just taking a picture it picks up
activity and it's
an area of the brain and found that when
you have them do a risky behavior and
look at their activity in their brain
conservatives were more likely to light
up in the fright and flight response
area the amygdala and liberals were more
likely to light up in areas that have to
do with social awareness again you could
see how therefore this difference would
inform what comes to the mind of either
a liberal or conservative while either
involved in a risky behavior or even
something that's happening external to
them but feels like it might impact them
in a risky way and that was actually
even more predictive than looking at
structure of the brain or what your
parents were in terms of liberal versus
conservative